tonight we are awaiting some more
information from henderson police on how
two children young children died at a
home in henderson
we do know it's being investigated right
now as a homicide
now according to police when paramedics
arrived to the home
near galleria and gibson they found a
one-year-old girl and a four-year-old
boy quote
beyond assistance sally jaramillo
returned to the neighborhood today and
people living there
are still in shock neighbors in this
henderson community say it's usually
quiet here but monday night
this area was surrounded by police
ambulances and fire trucks
the police officer's comment was i'll
never be the same after tonight
arianna mckeever has lived here for six
years she says she never saw children at
the house but would see a man taking out
trash
and checking mail mckeever was stunned
hearing something terrible
had happened nearby yesterday my
father-in-law comes running down the
stairs because his brother
is the chief of henderson fire
department and he was like what's your
guys address
because you know we just got a call
about a two and a four-year-old weber
says they were out for 30 minutes and
saw ambulances leaving with no one
inside
she also saw a woman running towards the
house she ran out of the car
to like go to the house and the police
stopped her and she was like my
grandbabies were my grandbabies
as for the children's father mckeever
says she saw him sitting on the curb for
two to three hours
then was placed in a police car but did
not see handcuffs
didn't shed a tear i know people say
shock hits you at different times but
if my children just died even if it was
accidental
if i accidentally did it there would be
motion
someone was either careless enough that
something did happen or they were
disgusting enough to do something
neighbors tell me they are planning a
candlelight vigil for the children this
wednesday at 6 30. reporting in
henderson sally caramillo 8 news now
henderson police have not revealed this
investigation involves the drowning of
these children or if they
even arrested anyone we're also awaiting
the identity of those children